it feels like khabib is one of the
hardest puzzles to solve
in in all of mixed martial arts if you
were to face khabib
do you think how would you go about
solving that puzzle
like almost the question is almost from
a jiu jitsu perspective too
what do you do with a guy that's
exceptionally good at controlling
position
especially on top very good at wrestling
and taking down and controlling position
like let's say so forget maybe striking
on the ground how do you solve
that guy like what do you do with your
guard if you get taken down or do you
create an entire system of not getting
taken down or escaping he's like what
what ideas do you have for that well i
guess i would say in my mind fighting is
a game of trading energy
um kind of uh you know there's two
there's two things there's damage and
there's energy
so like when i say energy has been like
uh tired not tired how much how much gas
you've got um and then damage counts
obviously as well
um you could be feeling i could be
feeling great and then you get to keep
me in the head hard really hard three
times it doesn't matter that i could get
up and run a mile i can't get up
so anyway um you know i think what
khabib does is
so well is he makes the fight look like
it could be the magneto fight um he does
a great job of avoiding damage
on the feet for the most part and really
sucking the life out of people with
how suffocating and oppressive is his
control is
his chain wrestling is as good as anyone
we've ever seen in the ufc it's
fantastic
um but uh that poses a really serious
threat for people that need to
maintain a certain amount of space and
try to hurt him on the feed because
unless they're able to inflict an
adequate amount of damage
they're gonna each time let's say for
instance let's say him taking them down
as a foregone conclusion at some point
um if every single time khabib takes you
down you get right back
up it's not that big a deal because it's
actually more we've all experienced this
let's say you and i are rolling he
tapped me 15 times in one round who's
more tired
probably you are yeah you what my ass so
badly that it's like you're the only one
working
but um so if you're comfortable
with the up and down of it like being
taken down if you're
if you don't if you don't get hurt badly
or tired on the bottom
you have a chance but that doesn't
involve just cracking him on the feet
before he gets a hold of you
that's a lot that's a lot to ask that's
a lot to ask that's difficult to do
it seemed actually like conor it seemed
like it when he was being kind of taken
down or the
the takedown attempts against khabib he
seemed to be
somewhat relaxed the whole thing i
thought he was doing well actually i
think that particularly for the first
round i thought he did a
very good job it's just one of those
things that i think like
could be being the fights taking place
in khabib's world
in large part and i mean set aside that
one giant uh
what is it right hand that that khabib
hit khanna with it by the way conor
reacted like an absolute champion he got
crushed by that overhand and then
dropped and his
eyes went right back on khabib it was
immediate positive great response so
even though that was i think
that was a bit of a surprising thing
conor reacted really really well but if
you're going to be on bottom with
khabib for four rounds that's going to
be tough and also conor is a way better
grappler than people like to give him
credit for
but he's not the type of grappler that
can do that can that can
that's too tall of an order but there
are grapplers that could do that or at
least would have a much much
better shot at uh being able to weather
that type of a storm
do you see yourself being able to be
relaxed through that kind of storm yes
well i guess
remember being beings being savagely
beaten is very relevant
the time that the timing of that answer
was like okay
that's a dumb question no that's
ultimately
the goal of jujitsu is to um be relaxed
to the fire right for sure and remember
like every ufc fighter i win all
hypothetical match-ups yeah
[Laughter]
that's true
you